era giusto quei due o tre anni che non
giocava gang bis ho riscoperto quanto è
figo solo recentemente quindi va dai
ragazzi allora sono quello questo tu
puoi andartene giu e l'unico che sta con
i suicidi di buongiorno
guardi il panorama lo apprezza meglio se
va giù buongiorno leila delle ali perché
le facciamo noi sfruttiamo allora
aggrapparti ma come fa rimanere
attaccato ma questo attaccato con la
cosa devi morire
mori ha scritto io vedo con piacere che
il gioco non è cambiato nel corso degli
anni sono molto contento siamo incontri
contro tre persone in tutto sto casino
con la si è svegliato adesso dove sta
scappando dove che scappa
in questo quadro lascio quanto more
porco demonio vieni qua dove mai
suicidato
ah no lì c'è qualcosa scendi vi aspetta
che non capisco cosa che c'è qua sotto a
un mandato il tizio o qualcuno si sta
picchiando con qualcuno come è possibile
che è successo dove la gente ho perso la
gente è così ma smettila ai piloti
estate piratesca poi over che muoio io
non lo sapevo solo morto io che pirla
sono morto aspetta aspetta va dai
ritorni perché è rimasto là va bene ce
n'è un'altra partita mi spieghi perché
vuoi attaccarti a qualsiasi cosa
attaccati al quello che pensi
levati porca vacca bravo buttalo giù
buttalo giù perché ti devi attacco su
questa attacca le cose non gioca si
attacca e basta
ma no ma sono venuto io lo sono trovate
a caso sono contattato non lo sanno loro
sono ancora attaccato e non lo sanno
se rimango qua attaccato loro muoiono e
vinco io che rimanga attaccato non vedo
niente devono esistere così ragazzi ecco
ho vinto io ero io sto attaccato
in fiera un fenomeno che poi lo zeppelin
una mongolfiera però facciamo finta di
niente ok facciamo finta di niente
allora fa mai cose fatte bene seri dove
che siede questo sergente calvo c con
lui stia calmo madonna che prende a
testate la gente insomma non c'è un
motivo vai vai sotto è mori sono sono
fortissimo al suo gioco
se fossi andato bene a scuola la metà di
controllo venissero gioco sarei tipo
einstein allora aspetta che devo tirare
testate al caldo tira testata che agrama
non fare lui era partito con l'elmetto
aie porco del demonio picchiare ritiro
delle testate pazzesca sono un fenomeno
nostro gioco comunque guardaroba guarda
faccio svenire la gente sono gravissimo
mi chiedo spaccati tutti ovviamente
suicidi perché ti calibrava fai bene
bravo è un tizio lo aspetta però mai
sotto ma non ti attaccare non di
attaccare minchiata ammazzo non tacca
due poli si ma sei pazzo a chi sa che
male ci vuole fare dai cogliere nicchia
che botta elevati grazie
picchia come ha fatto l'aggrapparsi così
un fenomeno devi morire
vai 18 dai non son riuscito a buttarla
giù per un niente e mori
sono ragazzi ho trovato il mio sport
cioè non sono brava rocket league ma in
questo me la cavo cioè questo posso
partecipare i tornei mondiali volendo
teoricamente aia ragazzi qua chi viene
prima ha perso mi sa io ho distaccati
devi staccare ti devi stoccolma cosa
prendi aiuto ai stai corato tutto ma
cosa fa questo mama all'ami mica
piuttosto di uccidermi si è suicidato
non attivare tutto questo ha vinto calvo
che è rimasto attaccato non è rimasto
perché l'altro dove è rimasta attaccata
container tipo io prima sulla zettel in
è un gioco storico questo madonna
ragazzi cattiveria sto già comunque sono
morto solo il suo livello livello stanno
continuando a due ore e mezza dove c'è
una persona che stava molestando un tubo
da due ore l'altra che stava molestando
la ringhiera e l'altra che stanno
destando il tipo che molesta al tubo io
sono morto nel primo secondo in tutto
questo perché sono caduto di sotto un
genio e la allora proprio lui salami
sandwich beh certo giocando con dei
premi nobel comunque non vorrei di
acquisto è quella di prima va bene
quella che non son riuscito che volevo
farla se possibile vorrei farlo con più
gente
vediamo se riusciamo tra una partita
conte finisco questa poi vedremo se
riesco a trovarlo in mano
miliardo di giocatori innanzitutto
tumori subito che inizia a giocare con
non ce n'è per nessuno rega morite tutti
tipo tu sei il primo esatto sono
cattivissimo olga è arrivo che vi siete
scambiati nel mezzo come questa roba
a me non mi invitate nel mentre ma come
fa ad averlo lui l'elmetto come è fatta
darglielo dallo anche a me non è giusto
madonna che botta togliti tu che dovuto
uccidere lui togliti form con il demonio
mori maori ecco fuori dal male e magari
quanto tempo che fa che cattiveria aiuto
questa mi vuole bene ne vuole mena
morire una testata vieni vieni
ecco vada via tra popoli per sempre lui
con chi è cattiveria la porta a casa
ragazzi sta vittorie sono le metto nei
curriculum come no mi carica funivia
funivie bellissima katy siamo ott un
account
salutami 5 attenzione occhio ai a mola
me ma ho la mia ex sente schifoso come
ti permetti mi chiedo è stato all'altro
non volevo che ne so io volevo tirati e
stato lui perché mi rompeva le ballad
iniziato a mori maori mori no richiesto
chiedendo aiuto aiuto è svenuto svenuti
tutti top già vacchia com'è possibile
come ha fatto morite non è riuscito non
è caduto è caduto l'alto si suicidavano
ragazzi come possibile no mica foto
stava facendo una cosa bellissima vista
buttando giù così cosa facciamo qua no
io non salto la fuga e salto a ci vieni
tu qua a me lo merito io ho fatto il
salto nella fede mori
no ecco che è tornato to die pezzente
schifoso
no no sono svenuto porca vacca che
buttare anche cattiveria nel liceo un
campione indiscusso tutti in un ace ci
sono due ascensori tutti nello stesso
dei geni come già accaduto non si sa
come con che fisica c'è l'ascensore
veramente mini come diavolo faccio
ragazzi sta crollando sta cadendo
ascensore aiuto sta accadendo
l'ascensore a ya basta
occhio che questo è svenuto cutolo giu
no ragazzi sta crollando sta crollando
l'ascensore sta crollando tutto sta che
non la rendono tutto all'accesso aiuti
mi sa che di proporre casacca ma succede
sono vivo sono vivo sono solo svenuto ma
sono vivo l'ascensore si è disintegrato
io sono vivo non so come aiuto sono vivo
sono vivo sono sono ancora io ahia ahia
io ho vinto io e caduto quello è caduto
ho vinto io da esso rimasto l'ultimo
ragazzi chimica per chi è rimasto visto
che vince non ho capito dove siamo dove
sono finiti gli altri però va bene e
questa è pericolanti ma come mette un
piede ma le sei morto esatto una morte
così questo sta morendo adesso se non
mori casena cause 2 dalmazzo io
occhio che occhio che questo cade cade
non può vincere perché lo stavano una
sega dai a borrelli vincere così
pezzente arrivo a
mi chiama che cattivo che sono lega c'è
proprio mi sento andrò all'inferno un
giorno uso o cristo ogni partita che
trovo ragazzi c'è sempre più gente
madonna vabbè menate vitrani voi io che
vedevo di vado avanti django proprio
convinto del fatto che tu sia django
guarda io ho una vecchia ma ci ha fatto
una vecchia ma la mia ma la palla è la
madonna
quant'è forte porco demonio questo se
cliccato in un tubo che di qua come vedi
jungle vai giù django ai a django che
male facciamo la vecchia regola buttarvi
giù la vecchia ma come tipi scontro
biblico è la madonna mollami come saputa
come faccio tutta la gente dai parenti
di cazzotti sono non c'è modo si chiama
pd che si studia ma mollami moriamo
tutti e due e sollevati sollevati porco
del demonio dai ragazzi po misseri aiap
che male ahi ahi ahi ahi ahi ahi a sono
di vostro dio cioè culo no no no alzati
alzati quanto tempo le ore per alzarti
madonna svenuto per terra per sei ore ha
vinto il rosso che tirava pugni al tubo
non voglio annunciandola 20 scherzavo
non sono pero se vivere come finisce
questa va bene ragazzi mentre vediamo il
finale io direi che fossero tutte le
cose grazie aver visto che stupido sono
molto soddisfatto della mia carriera
videoludica nel tempo perché comunque
arrivando da videogiochi un po stupidi
sim
all.ri pian piano sono cresciuto e oggi
giochiamo al proprio video vi sia
piaciuto ischia te al canale schiacciate
il tasto mi piace lasciate un commento
se volete che conti mi gang visse anche
perché da una vita che non lo facevo
vedo che è migliorato parecchio solo
nome non so cosa hanno cambiato ma è
molto più figuri prima ci rivediamo ad
un proxy non ci credo nemmeno
non posso chiudere il video se non muore
ci rivediamo il prossimo video beh
ragazzi
[Musica]
ma